[Música]
bueno
vamos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
una vez escuché
mueven
transacciones mueven a las ideas
yo no sé que tienen los veranos pero
como que en esos meses uno se replantea
la vida
y fue justo una tarde al tomar un
autobús que me llevaría a probar suerte
a otra ciudad cuando esto sucedió
un amigo de la familia me había
contactado para comentarme sobre una
entrevista de trabajo
sugirió que podía ser una muy buena
oportunidad para mí
se trataba de un trabajo en una nueva
ciudad y esto significaba empezar una
nueva vida
así que no lo pensé dos veces
me emocioné muchísimo y acepté la
invitación
días después mientras me dirigía a la
entrevista leía mi currículum que había
redactado apenas unas horas antes
tratando de que se me ocurrieron más
ideas para llenarlo porque la verdad es
que lucía algo vacío
en ese momento yo sabía que las
experiencias pasadas habían inyectados
nuevas perspectivas sueños y metas
y estaba segura de que esta era la
oportunidad perfecta para dar un gran
salto
sin embargo en muchas ocasiones
las cosas no suceden como esperamos
y es ahí donde las palabras hechas
conversación pueden jugar su magia
llegué a la entrevista y al poner un pie
en aquella oficina
un pensamiento comenzó a surgir en mi
mente
esto no es para ti
esa extraña sensación en la que uno no
está completamente seguro de lo que va a
ser
así que pasé de estar completamente
emocionada a tener muchas dudas es como
si de un momento a otro todo lo que
aparentemente querías cambiar
y un pensamiento comienza a decirte
y si éste resulta ser un trabajo que no
quiero
y si hay algo mejor
apuesto que en algún momento lo han
experimentado
para colmo ese mismo día me notificaron
que el trabajo era mío y me pidieron que
me presentara a la mañana siguiente
sin embargo
en mi mente ya se había definido la
respuesta
no aceptaría el trabajo
aún con esa sensación de incertidumbre
decidí salir un momento a la calle con
el pretexto de comprar algo y con el
temor de perderme porque en realidad no
conocía aquella ciudad pero a esas
alturas ya más perdidas no podía estar
de verdad
y mientras caminaba y reflexionaba sobre
si había tomado una buena decisión
mi celular sonó
y cuando voltea a ver la pantalla y vi
el nombre
honestamente no quise contestar
los minutos pasaron y nuevamente el
celular sonó
a esas alturas yo sabía que no tenía
opción
y en una esquina
en donde un árbol apenas daba sombra
una conversación comenzó a fluir
sabías que este puesto que pudo haber
situado en otro nivel
que pudiste haber aprendido y aportado
mucho
esas fueron algunas de las frases que
comencé a escuchar
y así una tras otra iban sacudiendo
todas las ideas de mi cabeza
recuerden que les dije que era verano
pues bien
aquella conversación duro
dos horas dos horas en las que estuve
prácticamente debajo del sol
creen que valió la pena todo ese tiempo
cómo terminó aquella conversación
las estadísticas dicen que siempre medio
vivimos
78 años
y tomando en cuenta la cantidad de
lugares que conoceremos a lo largo de
nuestra vida
habremos conocido a un promedio
de 80.000 personas
saben que esa cantidad es la capacidad
del estadio olímpico de londres
te imaginas con cuántas de estas
personas habremos compartido al menos
una conversación
cuántas de estas serán recordadas o
cuántas de estas habrán generado un
cambio en la vida
como resultado de aquellas dos horas
meses después decidí matricularme
nuevamente a la universidad en la
licenciatura de mercadotecnia y
publicidad
y por si fuera poco me animaron a
inscribirme a un curso de community
manager cosa que en su momento
honestamente yo no sabía lo que era ni
siquiera en que me iba a ayudar
y durante este periodo de aprendizaje
pude conocer diferentes aspectos sobre
las conversaciones
que inclusive hoy en día diariamente se
generan millones de estas gracias a los
medios digitales
y eso empiezo a recordar cuando decidí
hacer mi primer compra online
y fue gracias a que una marca conectó
conmigo en un momento especial en un
cumpleaños me envió un mensaje y un
cupón de descuento
ya en la carrera obviamente me di cuenta
de que fui
participe de toda una estrategia
mercadológica
pero lo cierto es que fue una marca que
conectó conmigo en un momento especial y
honestamente fue genial
lo que significa
que las conversaciones están migrando de
ser de persona a persona
a un nivel de comunicación entre marcas
y clientes
joseph deiss llamó a esto el marketing
conversacional
que tiene como objetivo enseñar a los
mercadólogos y a las empresas a cómo
volver a conectar con sus clientes a
través de una comunidad y el diálogo
esto quiere decir que las relaciones sea
cual sea el canal de comunicación
tienen su origen en una conversación
navegando un poco por la red me encontré
con un artículo de bill fisher titulado
reinventando las conversaciones para ser
más innovadores
y en este artículo el exponía
que a lo largo de la historia muchos
sucesos importantes en tecnología arte o
cultura se han originado
gracias a las conversaciones
puedes imaginarte cuántas ideas podrán
surgir entre nosotros en los próximos
minutos
son infinitas precisamente ese es el
objetivo de un té de c's y como decía la
canción de apertura del grupo calle 13
porque generamos más ideas que personas
hace unos meses
me quedé conversando con un joven
dicho sea de paso apenas nos conocíamos
éramos prácticamente extraños por lo que
en el momento en el que nos quedamos
solos en ese lugar un silencio incómodo
empezó a surgir entre nosotros
al cabo de unos minutos
supe que definitivamente alguien tenía
que hablar
y decidí hacerle las clásicas preguntas
que nunca fallan
sobre cómo está el trabajo cómo va la
familia los amigos
por lo que honestamente no esperaba
grandes respuestas sino solo hacer que
los minutos no fueran eternos
empezamos a platicar
y de un momento a otro
este joven empezó a compartir
información cada vez más íntima
sobre que no entendía por qué a sus
compañeros parecía irles bien en el
trabajo y el que se esforzaba que
trataba de hacer los principios
pues le sucedía todo lo contrario
la conversación siguió fluyendo
a tal grado
que llegó un punto en que el joven
comenzó a llorar
yo no sabía cómo reaccionar ante esta
situación
y es que llorar es algo es algo muy
íntimo
y es algo sobre lo que nosotros no nos
preparamos en nuestro día a día
pero este suceso
me hizo darme cuenta
que todos
en algún momento de nuestra vida
necesitamos un poco de comprensión
y esto se llama empatía
saben que la empatía es un rasgo
sumamente importante en las
conversaciones porque demuestra que nos
interesa lo que le sucede a las otras
personas lejos de solo centrarnos en
nosotros mismos
sin embargo
en los últimos 20 años
se ha visto un declive del 40% en los
indicadores de empatía entre los jóvenes
universitarios
esto es alarmante
y de estas cifras se derivan un sinfín
de problemas
el bullying es uno de ellos
por falta de empatía
he ahí la importancia de destinar el
tiempo y el lugar
para conversar
necesitamos conectarnos más y separarnos
menos
después de unos minutos
este joven comenzó a calmarse poco a
poco
y obviamente busque a animarlo y
alentarlo
pero al mismo tiempo trate de llevarlo a
un punto de reflexión
porque la empatía no siempre significa
tener que estar de acuerdo con la
persona
sino que se trata de entender el
problema o la situación
y entonces emitir nuestra opinión
había que trazar una estrategia
y al fin mercadóloga se me puso a prueba
para echar mano de todos los
conocimientos adquiridos
así que decidí contarle a este joven mi
historia con el mejor contenido posible
porque no basta sólo con entenderte
sino que voy a aportar a tu vida por
medio de mis conversaciones
cómo hacer entonces que nuestras
conversaciones tengan valor y calidad
estudios hechos por cherry tórculo
demuestran
que las primeras generaciones de niños
que crecieron con teléfonos inteligentes
no saben cómo entablar una conversación
esto es increíble
vivir en una era hiperconectada con
acceso a información 24/7
y no tener idea de qué y cómo decir
para fortuna de este joven parece
momento de la conversación ya había
leído al menos unos libros y había
navegado por internet en artículos
los cuales me permitieron echar mano de
información valiosa
de lo contrario le soy sincera no sé que
hubiera terminado diciendo y cómo
hubiera reaccionado
no trate de decirle lo que tenía que
hacer
si no busque llevarlo a un proceso de
pensar a través de preguntas
hablamos sobre que no todos avanzamos al
mismo tiempo en lo laboral sentimental
educativo
y que los principios sean las
circunstancias que sean jamás deben ser
pisoteados porque son la base de quiénes
somos
hace poco volvimos a tener comunicación
y fue un gusto saber que este joven
ahora amigo está más tranquilo sobre sus
objetivos de vida
es más acaba de graduarse de la
licenciatura en enfermería
y hoy está más que listo para enfrentar
los nuevos retos de la vida
porque no basta con decir
sino que decir
porque en la medida en que usemos el
lenguaje
éste tendrá la capacidad de influir de
manera destructiva o constructiva
y eso me puso a pensar en que muy pocas
veces
en nuestro caminar diario
escuchamos cosas que realmente nos
nutren
que nos hacen ver la vida desde otra
perspectiva y que nos invitan a
cuestionar el por qué y para qué hacemos
las cosas
te has detenido a escuchar de qué habla
la gente en el transporte público
en la fila del banco
en la escuela en el trabajo
inclusive en tu familia
son cosas que aportan valor
mira que tampoco estoy diciendo que hay
que ir por la vida filosofando por todos
lados
pero si es una invitación
a que tengamos un momento del que todos
podamos ser partícipes
para compartir contenidos interesantes y
que nos ayuden a crecer como personas
en la actualidad existen muchas pero
muchas formas de comunicarnos
de manera análoga como lo que estamos
haciendo en este momento es decir cara a
cara
de manera sincrónica gracias a los
medios digitales
de manera intrapersonal como si fuéramos
la voz en off de una película
inclusive las personas con discapacidad
pueden conversar gracias a otro tipo de
medios
stephen hawking por ejemplo
y es que las conversaciones
han sido la base para la gestión de la
democracia los negocios la educación y
la cultura y sobre la que se desarrollan
relaciones aprendizaje y crecimiento
lo que nos hace únicos como seres
y dejar de desarrollarla
es condenarnos a perder
nuestra identidad
porque todos somos la suma de nuestras
conversaciones
hace un año yo no tenía trabajo
ni siquiera esperanza de regresar a la
universidad
pero hoy estoy aquí gracias a una
conversación
eso no quiere decir que de ella vamos a
obtener el abc de las cosas que tenemos
que hacer
pero si necesitamos comprender
que puede mostrarnos dónde empezar un
nuevo camino
ya lo decía un escritor
que llegaría el momento de desarrollar
una nueva ambición
por desarrollar no el habla
sino la conversación que cambia las
personas
y este momento es ahora
porque la magia de la conversación
radica en llegar a un punto de fusión
tan íntima que los individuos
inevitablemente terminen siendo
diferentes a como lo eran al principio
porque la verdadera conversación
prende fuego
deseas generar cambios
una conversación es el mejor inicio
gracias
[Aplausos]